ian puede podar el pasto del jardín y
meter todas las hojas en bolsas en 5
horas
andrei puede podar el pasto del mismo
jardín y meter las hojas en bolsas en 3
horas si trabajan juntos cuánto tiempo
se tardarán en podar el pasto y meter
las hojas en bolsas ok entonces y él
puede podar el pasto del jardín y meter
las hojas en bolsas en 5 horas
gates 5 horas así es que vamos a poner
por aquí una y de día y lo que nos dice
es que ían puede terminar con un jardín
jar
que a lo largo de este vídeo vamos a
estar hablando siempre del mismo jardín
pero bueno ya termina de trabajar con
este jardín en 5 horas
horas gay y en todo el pasto y recoge
todas las bolsas de un jardín en cinco
horas y como puedes notar esto es una
proporción y también pudimos haber
puesto que ya tarda cinco horas en
terminar con un jardín pero como vamos a
ver esta va a ser más sutil entonces
esta es una proporción o también
podríamos decir que es una taza o la
velocidad aunque queda mejor como la
velocidad con la que en poda el pasto y
mete las hojas en las bolsas y de hecho
es igual
un quinto de jardín
jardín por hora
ok su velocidad es un quinto de jardines
por hora
así es que pues hagamos lo mismo con
andrei tenemos que andrei puede podar el
pasto del mismo jardín y meter las hojas
en bolsas en tres horas y entonces vamos
a poner aquí una a de andrei
y andrei todo el pasto y mete las hojas
de un jardín un jardín que es este mismo
jardín en tres horas
y entonces su velocidad es de un tercio
de jardines por hora de jardín por
ahora ahora lo que nos están preguntando
es si trabajan juntos cuánto tiempo se
tardarán en podar el pasto y meter las
ocas en bolsas entonces nosotros
queremos saber cuánto es y hay más
andrei y para averiguar eso digamos que
te es igual a cuánto tiempo se tardan en
poder el pasto y meter las hojas en
bolsas trabajando juntos
igual a cuánto tiempo cuánto
un poco se tarda
tarde
y trabajan juntos trabajan juntos juntos
entonces si están trabajando juntos van
a terminar con un jardín
jardín en de horas
y ahora sí que asumiendo que está t este
tiempo lo estamos midiendo en horas y
entonces su velocidad
1 / t jardín por horas
por horas
ok entonces en cada hora van a terminar
con una décima parte del jardín así es
que su velocidad es uno entre este
jardín por horas que entonces aquí
tenemos su velocidad como trabajan
juntos aquí tenemos la velocidad con la
que ían trabaja y aquí tenemos la
velocidad con la que andré y trabaja
pero la velocidad con la que trabajan
juntos tiene que ser igual a la
velocidad con la que trabaja y en más la
velocidad con la que trabaja andrei
porque pues en una hora y han va a ser
una quinta parte del jardín y andrei va
a ser una tercera parte del jardín
entonces en una hora trabajando los dos
juntos habrán hecho una quinta parte más
una tercera parte entonces su velocidad
trabajando juntos es
un quinto jardín por ahora pero ya vamos
a dejar de escribir eso del jardín por
ahora para no escribir tanto pero tú
recuerda que es un jardín por ahora y
bueno entonces es un quinto de jardín
por ahora más la velocidad con la que
andré y trabaja que es un tercio de
jardín por ahora o sea nada
un tercio de jardín por ahora eso es
igual a la velocidad a la que avanzan si
los dos trabajan juntos que es uno entre
jardín por horas o sea 1 entre t ok
entonces queremos averiguar cuánto vale
t así es que vamos a resolver esta
ecuación y de este lado lo que tenemos
es un quinto más un tercio que tiene
como un denominador 15 entonces lo que
tenemos por aquí es 3
seamos más 515 a vos
5 15 a bush y eso es igual a 1 / t y 315
años más 5 15 a vos
esos son 8 15 a vos y aquí tenemos que
eso es igual a 1 entre t aquí entonces
si lo que queremos es conseguir t lo que
podemos hacer es tomar el recíproco de
los dos lados de la ecuación y entonces
lo que obtenemos voy a seguir por acá
es el recíproco de 815 a vos es quince
octavos y el recíproco de uno entre t es
igual a t entre uno que es simplemente
una t entonces ya tenemos que te es
igual a quince octavos pero nos faltó
eso de las unidades verdad entonces
saber aquí lo que teníamos
hardy
por ahora
ok entonces a la hora de tomar el
recíproco de intercambiar este número
con este número y lo mismo aquí pues
también tenemos que cambiar estos dos
entonces lo que nos queda es horas por
jardín
dyn que teníamos aquí que entre ian y
andrei podaban y arreglaban ocho veces
el jardín en 15 horas y entonces tomamos
el recíproco y eso lo que nos dice es
que ya ni andrei se tardan 15 horas en
podar y arreglar 8 jardines ok aquí
también tenemos horas entre jardín muy
bien entonces ya por fin encontramos
cuánto tiempo se tardan en podar el
jardín y arreglarlos y trabajan juntos
ok que es 15 octavos porque se tardan 15
octavos de hora en arreglar un jardín y
nos estamos preguntando en cuánto tiempo
se tardan en arreglar un jardín así es
que ya tenemos que se tardan 15 octavos
de hora que es igual a 15 octavos de
hora
pero tal vez queremos esta cantidad de
una forma explícita entonces quince
octavos de hora eso es igual a un entero
y siete octavos de hora para sacar siete
octavos de hora pues vamos a sacar
nuestra calculadora y tenemos siete
octavos que es igual a punto 8 75 pero
cada hora tiene 60 minutos entonces
vamos a multiplicar por 60 y nos queda
52.5 entonces siete octavos de ahora son
50 y 2.5 minutos y en y andrei si
trabajan juntos se tardan una hora
a 52.5 minutos minutos en arreglar todo
el jardín sea podar el pasto y meter las
hojas en las bolsas bueno espero que te
haya parecido útil este vídeo y nos
vemos en el próximo